today I want to share with you a neat
way to solve the towers of Hanoi puzzle
just by counting in a different number
system and surprisingly this stuff
relates to finding a curve that fills
her Pinsky's triangle I learned about
this from a former CS lecturer of mine
his name is Keith Schwartz and I've got
to say this man is one of the best
educators that I've ever met I actually
recorded a bit of the conversation where
he showed me this stuff so you guys can
hear some of what he described directly
it's weird I'm not normally the sort of
person who likes little puzzles and
games but I just love looking at the
analysis of puzzles and games and I love
just looking at mathematical patterns
that come from in case you're unfamiliar
let's just lay down what the towers of
Hanoi puzzle actually is so you have a
collection of three pegs and you have
these disks of descending size you think
of these disks as having a hole in the
middle so that you can fit them onto a
peg the setup pictured here has five
disks which all labeled 0 1 2 3 4 but in
principle you could have as many disks
as you want so they all start up stacked
up from biggest to smallest on one
spindle and the goal is to move the
entire tower from one spindle to another
the rule is you can only move one disk
at a time and you can't move a bigger
disk on top of a smaller disk
for example your first move must involve
moving disks zero since any other disk
has stuff on top of it that needs to get
out of the way before it can move after
that you can move disk one but it has to
go on whatever peg doesn't currently
have disk zero since otherwise you'd be
putting a bigger disk on a smaller one
which isn't allowed if you've never seen
this before I highly encourage you to
pause and pull out some books of varying
sizes and try it out for yourself just
kind of get a feel for what the puzzle
is if it's hard why it's hard if it's
not why it's not that kind of stuff
now Keith showed me something truly
surprising about this puzzle which is
that you can solve it just by Counting
up in binary and associating the rhythm
of that counting with a certain rhythm
of disk movements for anyone unfamiliar
with binary I'm gonna take a moment to
do a quick overview here first actually
even if you are familiar with binary I
want to explain it with a focus on the
rhythm of counting which you may or may
not have thought about before any
description of binary typically starts
off with an introspection about our
usual way to represent numbers what we
call base 10 since we use 10 separate
digits 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 the rhythm of
counting begins by walking through all
10 of these digits
then having run out of new digits you
expressed the next number ten with two
digits one zero you say that one is in
the tens place since it's meant to
encapsulate the group of ten that you've
already counted up to so far while
freeing the ones place to reset to zero
the rhythm of counting repeats like this
counting up nine rolling over to the
tens place counting up nine more rolling
over to the tens place etc until after
repeating that process nine times you
roll over to a hundreds place
a digit that keeps track of how many
groups of 100 you've hit freeing up the
other two digits to reset to zero
in this way the rhythm of counting is
kind of self-similar even if you zoom
out to a larger scale the process looks
like doing something rolling over doing
that same thing rolling over and
repeating nine times before an even
larger roll over
in binary also known as base to you
limit yourself to two digits 0 & 1
commonly called bits which is short for
binary digits the result is that when
you're counting you have to roll over
all the time after counting 0 1 you've
already run out of bits so you need to
roll over to a twos place writing 1 0 &
resisting every edge in your base 10
trained brain to read this as 10 and
instead understand it to mean one group
of two plus zero then increment up to 1
1 which represents 3 and already you
have to roll over again and since
there's a 1 in that twos place that has
to roll over as well giving you 1 0 0
which represents one group of 4 plus 0
groups of 2 plus 0 in the same way that
digits in base 10 represent powers of 10
bits in base 2 represent different
powers of 2 so instead of talking about
a tens place a hundreds place a
thousands place things like that you
talk about a twos place a fours place
and an eighth place the rhythm of
counting is now a lot faster but that
almost makes it more noticeable flip the
last roll over once flip the last roll
over twice flip the last roll over once
flip the last roll over three times
again there's a certain self similarity
to this pattern at every scale the
process is to do something roll over
then do that same thing again
at the small scale say counting up to
three which is one one in binary
this means flip the last bit roll over
to the twos then flip the last bit at a
larger scale by counting up to 15 which
is 1 1 1 1 in binary the process is to
let the last 3 count up to 7 roll over
to the eights place then let the last 3
bits count up again counting up to 255
which is eight successive ones this
looks like letting the last 7 bits count
up till they're full rolling over to the
hundred twenty eighths place then
letting the last 7 bits count up again
alright so with that mini introduction
the surprising fact that Keith showed me
is that we can use this rhythm to solve
the towers of Hanoi you start by
counting from zero whenever you're only
flipping that last bit from a zero to a
one
move disks zero one peg to the right
if it was already on the rightmost peg
you just loop it back to the first peg
you
if in your binary counting you roll over
once to the twos place meaning you flip
the last two bits you move disk number
one where do you move it you might ask
well you have no choice you can't put it
on top of disk zero and there's only one
other peg so you move it where you're
forced to move it so after this counting
up to one one that involves just
flipping the last bit so you move disk
zero again
then when your binary counting rolls
over twice to the fours place move disk
number two and the pattern continues
like this flip the last move disk zero
flip the last to move disk one flip the
last move disk zero and here we're gonna
have to roll over three times to the
eights place and that corresponds to
moving disc number three there's
something magical when I first saw this
like this can't work like I don't know
how this works
I don't know why this works now I know
but it's just magical when you see it
and I remember putting any other
animation for this for when I was
teaching this and just like you know I
know how this works I know all the
things in it it's still fun to just sit
and just like watch it play out oh yeah
I mean it's not even clear at first that
this is always gonna give legal moves
for example how do you know that every
time you're rolling over to the eighth
place the disk three is necessarily
gonna be freed up to move at the same
time the solution just immediately
raised these questions like where does
this come from why does this work and is
there a better way of doing this then
having to do 2 to the N minus 1 steps it
turns out not only does this solve
towers of Hanoi but it does it in the
most efficient way possible
understanding why this works and how it
works and what the heck is going on
comes down to a certain perspective on
the puzzle what's es folk might call a
recursive perspective just 3 is thinking
ok two-one-zero like you have to get you
have to get off of him like I can't I
can't really function under this much
weighted pressure and so just from just
threes perspective if you want to figure
out how is just 3 gonna get over here
somehow I don't care how this to 1 and 0
have to get to spindle T that's the only
way they can move any of these
distraught on top of 3 I can't move that
any of them are in spindle C it can't
move there so somehow we have to get to
1
zero having done that then we can move
disc three over there and the district
says I'm said you never need to move me
again everyone else just figure out how
to get here and in a sense you now have
a smaller version of the same problem
now you've got two zero one and two
sitting on spindle B you got to get them
to C so the idea is that if I just focus
on one disc and I think about what am I
gonna have to do to get this disc to
work I can turn my bigger problem into
something slightly smaller and then how
do I solve that well it's exactly the
same thing disc 2 is gonna say this one
does 0 you need to you know it's not you
it's me I just need some space get off
they need to move somewhere then just
two can move to where it needs to go
than just one and zero can do this but
the interesting point is that every
single disc pretty much has the exact
same strategy they all say everybody let
me get off then I'm going to move okay
everyone come back on when you know that
insight you can code up something that
will solve towers of noise like five or
six lines of code which probably has the
highest ratio of like intellectual
investment lines of code ever and if you
think about it for a bit it becomes
clear that this has to be the most
efficient solution at every step you're
only doing what's forced upon you you
have to get disks 0 through 2 off before
you can move discs 3 and you have to
move discs 3 and then you have to move
discs 0 through 2 back onto it there's
just not any room for inefficiency from
this perspective so why does counting in
binary capture this algorithm well
what's going on here is that this
pattern of solving a sub-problem moving
a big disk then solving a subproblem
again is perfectly paralleled by the
pattern of binary counting count up some
amount roll over count up to that same
amount again and this towers of Hanoi
algorithm and binary counting are both
self similar processes in the sense that
if you zoom out and count up to a larger
power of 2 or solve towers of Hanoi with
more disks they both still have that
same structure subproblem do a thing
subproblem for example at a pretty small
scale solving towers of Hanoi for 2 days
move disks zero move disk one move disk
zero is reflected by counting up to
three in binary flip the last bit roll
over once flip the last bit at a
slightly larger scale solving towers of
Hanoi for three disks looks like doing
whatever it takes to solve two disks
move disk number two then do whatever it
takes to solve two disks again
analogously counting up to one one one
in binary involves counting up to three
rolling over all three bits then
counting up three more at all scales
both processes have this same breakdown
so in a sense the reason that this
binary solution works or at least an
explanation if you like you know there's
no one explanation but I think the most
natural one is that the pattern you
would use to generate these binary
numbers has exactly the same structure
as the pattern you would use for towers
of Hanoi which is why if you look at the
bits flipping you're effectively
reversing this process you're saying
what process generated these like if I
were trying to understand how these bits
work flips to give me this thing you're
effectively reverse engineering the
recursive algorithm for towers of Hanoi
which is why it works out that's pretty
cool right but it actually gets cooler I
haven't even gotten to have this relates
to sierpinski's triangle and that's
exactly what I'm gonna do in the
follow-on video part 2 many thanks to
everybody who's supporting these videos
on patreon I just finished the first
chapter of essence of calculus and I'm
working on the second one right now and
patreon supporters are getting early
access to these videos before I publish
the full series in a few months
this video and the next one are also
supported in part by desmos and before
the next video I just want to take a
moment and share with you guys a little
about who they are and the fact that
they're hiring so desmos is actually
really cool they make a lot of these
interactive math activities for
classrooms and tools for teachers the
real meat of their offering is in their
classroom activities for my part I'm
super impressed by just how well
thought-out these activities are from a
pedagogical standpoint the team clearly
knows their stuff and they know where
they stand to make a difference in
students and teachers lives and like I
said they're hiring they are always
looking to bring in more good talent
whether that's engineering talent
designers teachers or whatever other
skill sets line up with what they want
to do if any of you out there are
interested in joining them you know
helping them make some of these great
tools for teachers and students you can
check out the careers page that I've
linked in the description personally I
think they're doing some really
meaningful stuff I think their
activities are building genuinely good
math intuitions for students and the
world could use a few more talented
people pointing their efforts towards
education the way that they do alright
so with that I'll see you guys next
video and I think you're really gonna
like where this is going
you
[Music]
you